[Music]
hey guys Dave here and welcome to
another GS news update with Mass Effect
Andromeda is scheduled to arrive later
this year the game's development is
moving along while the game remains
largely a mystery AB iOS developer
recently played through the first hour
and shared his thoughts and almost
shared a little too much on Monday
Bioware edmonton's Cameron Lee who is
not on the game's development team
played through the first 60 minutes of
the game as you'd expect he didn't give
too much away but he nearly did say he
almost accidentally tweeted a picture of
the game's executable he summed up the
first hour of Mass Effect Andromeda with
was fun and I got to shoot things in the
face smiley emoji Lee is a lead producer
at Bioware Edmonton he worked on 2014's
acclaimed RPG Dragon Age Inquisition and
is now part of the team that's making a
brand new IP in other news about
Andromeda the game's senior development
director chris win quit Bioware at the
end of 2015 it is not yet announced what
he's doing next after his departure was
made public Bioware confirm that
development on Andromeda was continuing
at full pace and rubber the launches in
fall 2016 for pc playstation 4 and xbox
one with a new teaser trailer being
released in november so are you excited
to launch back into the intergalactic
world of mass effect let us know in the
comment section below or you can find me
on Twitter at a regular Dave and for
your mass effect news stay tuned to
gamespot com
[Music]